that is our first example let's think of
a more curly one where you see why I
need all three of them okay
let's consider this guy okay if we
consider the same point if we consider
the same point I'm not going to draw it
I wonder if you can picture it in your
mind without me drawing if I consider X
equal zero then when I come from the
left zero negative okay as I come from
the left I'm having small negative
values but they're being squared aren't
they they're being squared so therefore
I'm going to be where am I going I'm
going up to infinity right these are
microscopically small numbers really
really small numbers on the domain which
means the whole thing is me it's
approaching positive infinity
okay in this case no it doesn't so if
I'm approaching I'm going to be and I'll
show you this in a second um why it
doesn't matter how fast you do it as
long as you do when I come from the
other side from the right okay 1 over x
squared you're still getting
astronomically small numbers on the
denominator that's more really really
small right so small numbers in the
other donnelly no it's really really big
numbers in total it's still going to
infinity
now it's squared it's squared right so
here's what I've established so far
right he's almost average so far I have
this part approaching from the left
approaching from the right same value of
course once I get to this guy though I'm
in trouble I'm in it because I'm
dividing by zero right so this guy is
undefined so what's going on okay let's
draw this guy this drawing this guy he
looks almost exactly the same as that
almost
that's not bad all right which of course
you could have told me before because
right here right here see how that's a -
that's a - it's an even power which
means what kind of symmetry you
expecting even symmetry just like you
have one symmetry here makes sense yes
yeah yeah okay so that's a great
question if the question is supplied to
you in a useful way if you're trying to
you see to talk about any of this you
need to have the function has to have
some kind of name right if it was this
it was y equals 1 over X strictly
speaking you can say this right because
Y is a function and the variable you can
stick into it is X but it's a bit weird
because like who knows whether that's Y
is a function of X or Y is x exercise
it's it's a bit ambiguous really so if
it doesn't get given to you in this ball
I put it in that form just so that you
can actually say this and and you can
refer to this definition so that's a
certainty right I've got x equals 0
where I'm undefined
this by the way gets to UM the question
as we asked before this guy approaches
what's that horizontal asymptote there
horizontal asymptote is y equal zero
right now one on x squared is it going
to approach that asymptote faster or
slower than this guy would you think
hmm this is I'm just gonna give all the
answers
hello mrs. throw everything if something
will stick right let's just think about
this right we're going towards zero
right okay pick a number zero zero is it
easy to work with
okay now at x equals 100 and x equals
100 how close am I to my asymptote here
answer I'm at I'm at one over 100 right
okay at the same point how close is this
guy it's up whatever ten thousand which
one is closer yes it's exactly right so
Chris pasa map but he's the point you
climb back to original question it's
still asymptotic to y equals zero it is
no more assets like oh I'm really really
asking Tony where is this guy's just
like that's inside they're both
asymptotic right that's that's exactly
right um so it doesn't matter where they
want to purchase fast that most off
they're still I can still gird
arbitrarily close I just have to go a
bit further with this guy tonight a
hundred times further but that's okay I
could do it